now there are five signs and symptoms
that i believe you should never cover up
with a medication and of course before
you take any action with this
information
check with your doctor but
symptoms
are one of the ways that your body
communicates to you and if you suppress
the symptom
you cover up the communication and
sometimes the medication creates more
harm than good and so when i talk about
these five symptoms
there are much better natural solutions
out there which i will also talk about
but one thing you have to realize is
that a symptom is not the cause it's a
symptom and it's
an indication that there's a problem so
you always want to dive in and see what
is causing this problem
so let's start with number one
having a stuffy nose a lot of the
medications for um
sinus problems actually cause a
shrinkage of congested blood vessels
okay
the problem is they usually only work
for three days and then you develop a
tolerance for that medication and either
you need more medication or it just
doesn't work anymore not to mention
giving you other side effects like
insomnia like high blood pressure so if
you have a stuffy nose
i would definitely try something natural
first there's certain type of nasal um
sea salt rinses that you can use
i just did a video on using a nebulizer
which i'm going to put a link down below
very important video if you have any
type of respiratory problems so a
nebulizer takes a liquid and turns it
into a mist so it can invade your
sinuses and your lungs and
really penetrate a lot deeper but
there's a great combination of using
garlic oil
iodine black seed
sea salt and colloidal silver all right
next one is the common cold or flu now
the common cold or the flu are viruses
and if you treat a virus infection with
an antibiotic you're wasting your time
and you're going to create a lot of side
effects because
so many people are developing
antibiotic resistance
and there's even 35 000 people a year
in the us that die
from antibiotic resistance so
the overuse of antibiotics causes your
microbes to adapt grow stronger and it's
very similar to what's happening out
there with using pesticides with
different plants the pests become
resistant the weeds become resistant and
they don't work because nature is always
trying to evolve and survive
encounter and develop certain mechanisms
to survive stronger so for the common
cold for the flu
you definitely want to start with
vitamin d
i think a lot of the flu in the winter
is really just a vitamin d deficiency
because one of the symptoms of low
vitamin d
is increased susceptibility
to viral infections and it also creates
a great weakness for your own immune
system i mean just a
chicken soup for example has the ability
to suppress neutrophils and concentrate
neutrophils in certain parts of your
body
to increase your immune system and
overcome certain types of
viral infections now neutrophils are the
main line of white blood cells for any
infections
neutrophils are involved in all the
mucus that you generate
and so chicken soup is a very simple
natural thing that you can do but the
other things that i always recommend are
definitely vitamin d d3 i would take at
least 20 000 international units
zinc
at least 40 milligrams i would be doing
garlic i would do vitamin c and natural
vitamin c at least 500 milligrams and i
would do that on a regular basis really
good for viral infections all right
let's talk about constipation
i had a lady who came to my office
years ago
that was so constipated
she would go every single month
okay a month i'm not kidding
now she didn't even come in for
constipation she came in wanting to lose
weight and i said no no no we have to
focus on constipation because
you're not going to lose weight if
you're not going to the bathroom and
even over-the-counter laxatives just
stop working for her one of the problems
with laxatives is the side effects you
can lose electrolytes you can have
rebound constipation
it can inactivate your own muscles and
nerves in your colon
your large intestine
and cause some dependence on that
laxative especially if you're doing a
medication versus a natural herbal
laxative which is works a lot
differently but there's some real
natural things that i would always try
first one would be a
prebiotic which is um like vegetables
and a probiotic
which is friendly bacteria now if you
combine both of those together you have
things like sauerkraut or fermented
vegetables
very very good for constipation your
microbes help you
break down
fiber they help you break down foods
they help make vitamins but if you don't
have the right diversity of microbes
you can get easily constipated i mean
think about what happens after you take
an antibiotic it wipes out your friendly
bacteria and one big side effect is
constipation another thing that will
help constipation is a lot of potassium
the other thing that will do it would be
mct oil
it creates a laxative effect
and then also bile salts purify bio
salts one way that you know you're
taking too many bile salts is that you
it creates a laxative effect but many
times you might be constipated just
because you don't have enough bile
bile helps to lubricate the colon
vitamin b1 can also help
the pumping action of the colon the
peristalsis and also in a minute fasting
if you're eating so frequently with
snacks and you're just cramming all this
food into this pipe that's literally you
know close to 30 35 feet then maybe your
cola never has a chance to reset and
clean out
so intermittent fasting is very very
important to kind of reset the whole
system and a lot of people get rid of
their constipation when they start
intermittent fasting all right next
topic is insomnia over-the-counter sleep
aids okay medications
many times they'll use repurposed
medication like antihistamines that were
used for allergies but they found one of
the effects side effects is drowsiness
and now they repurpose it for a sleep
medication the problem is there's major
side effects especially when you wake up
i remember when i was in high school
i had a job working at the
kenosha i think news i don't think it
was a kenosha gazette it might have been
the kenosha news
i would have to go there
um third shift okay
and help
assemble the newspaper downstairs for
delivery in the morning and i'll never
forget this was in the winter time when
it was like 20 below zero and so i had
to drive
at 20 below zero take the battery in
uh into the house and then put it back
in the my car to then drive to this
the kenosha news at two o'clock in the
morning
the problem is i had to get some sleep
before this so what did i do i used an
antihistamine to try to get some sleep
all it did was make me completely drowsy
when i was trying to work and it didn't
help me sleep one iota but a lot of
different medications that they use for
insomnia are just repurposed like anti
anxiety medication
antidepressants
okay have certain side effects of making
you tired
and so this is what people are taking to
help them sleep these have major side
effects they slow the central nervous
system down they can cause dependence
and addiction so
um there are much
better things to use like vitamin d
before bed like 20 000 i use a vitamin d
really good for sleeping
doing physical work to actually get your
body tired especially if you were an
athlete if you were an athlete let's say
in high school or college
and
you are 40 50 years old and you have not
kept up that level of physical activity
your mitochondria are so large
that they generate so much energy that
you're gonna have a hard time sleeping
so you're gonna have to do more physical
work or exercise to drain out this
energy so you can sleep also getting the
infrared from the sun can increase your
melatonin
if you have not seen my video on that
very important video i put that down
below also celery
is a great remedy for sleep like four
stalks of celery in the evening getting
your breathing um calm down when you
sleep very very important you can
control the autonomic nervous system
by regulating your breathing through
your sinuses
and slowing it down
and relaxing i have a really good video
on that one as well i'll put that down
below as well and magnesium is also a
good remedy for sleeping and the last
symptom i want to talk about
is a fever a fever is
a normal body reaction to an infection
usually and your body realizes that
these viruses these pathogenic viruses
cannot survive
in high levels of heat so your body is
just heating up to help you get rid of
them
your own body's microbes can live in
heat but viruses cannot so it's a real
good mechanism for wiping out viruses
and then when you take something like
nsaid or acetaminophen
or aspirin you're basically increasing
the duration of infection
you are weakening your own immune system
having a fever is part of what's called
the acquired immune system
is this training for your white blood
cells so many people
freak out when they get sick or when
their kids get sick but getting sick is
a normal immune reaction to the
environment as long as you give your
immune system a chance to overcome this
infection so you don't want to kill off
the fever right away then you can start
strengthening your immune system the
real problem with complications from
pathogens is
other co-morbidities like
insulin resistance like other health
problems weaknesses within other systems
whether you're a diabetic whether you're
grossly overweight whether you have a
history of heart problems that's when
you have problems
with immune reactions
so just another reason why you should
focus on
getting healthy and strengthening your
immune system now if you have not seen
my immune system video which has been
very popular check it out i put it right
here